con parte de la agenda política de los
demócratas y del presidente yo bailé en
está en juego esta semana y podría
definirse este jueves el momento es tan
delicado que byd en todo hay que
cancelar su viaje a chicago para tratar
de negociar con congresistas moderados y
progresistas de su partido las
diferencias que hay en proyectos que
suman más de 4,5 billones de dólares lo
más urgente es asegurar que antes del
jueves a la medianoche se logre un
acuerdo para financiar la operación del
gobierno hasta el 3 de diciembre esto lo
querían hacer pasar los demócratas en un
paquete que incluía la suspensión del
techo de la deuda pero los republicanos
en el senado se opusieron al paquete lo
más probable entonces es que entre hoy
mañana los demócratas presenten una
nueva ley de presupuesto sin el techo de
la deuda empaquetado para así lograr que
el gobierno siga funcionando otro
proyecto que se definiría el jueves
sería la aprobación del plan de
infraestructura de un billón de dólares
en la cámara de representantes pero los
demócratas progresistas de la cámara
amenazaron sólo aprobarán este proyecto
si los demócratas moderados liderados
por los senadores joe manchin y krysten
sinema en el senado aprueban un programa
social de 3.5 billones de dólares
negociaciones que podrían no cumplir el
límite que se autoimpusieron los
demócratas pero que podría aprobarse en
las próximas semanas lo que sí terminará
probándose y de forma independiente en
los próximos días será la suspensión del
techo de la deuda que según el tesoro
tendría que hacerse antes del 18 de
octubre para que eeuu no incumpla sus
pagos y caiga en un default o por
primera vez en su historia hecho que
tendría grandes consecuencias económicas
para todos los estadounidenses